so will you apologize for it would be
helpful if he could retract his
inappropriate comment from last night
I've examined that list very carefully I
cannot identify a single terrorist
sympathizer among that will he know
apologize for his deeply insulting
remark should he not take this
opportunity to withdraw the remarks that
he is calling those who will not be
voting with him tonight a bunch of
terrorist sympathizers because not only
is that offensive it is dangerous and it
is untrue will he take this further
opportunity to identify which members of
these benches he regards as terrorist
sympathizers he must apologize for the
[ __ ] that was put on every member of the
Opposition last night what do it now I
met some a proper to be in just a final
word can I give him some motherly advice
if he now just got up and said whoever
does not walk with me through the
division lobby is not a terrorist step
aside he would he would improve his
standing in his house and knows with the
Prime Minister now you withdraw his
remarks
if the Prime Minister now wants to
apologize for those remarks I'd be happy
to give way to him to do so
you